With the success of the SCP Foundation, in
spite of all its attempts at secrecy, there
have always been imitators.
Looking at you, Catch, Secure, and Prevent
Society.
What are you going to call yourselves, the
CSP Foundation?
You just look ridiculous.
No matter how many copycats try their hand
at tracking and containing anomalous activity,
there’s only one SCP Foundation.
Well, sort of.
We should say, there’s only one SCP Foundation
per universe.
There are an unknowable number of alternate
universes out there, and many of those have
their own version of the SCP Foundation.
However, these alternate versions of the Foundation
don’t tend to interact outside of the absolute
worst-case scenario.
According to the 1981 Multi-Foundation Coalition
Agreement, in the event of an irreversible
XK-Class Event - or, you know, Apocalypse
- any relevant documents will be automatically
distributed to the members of all other versions
of the Foundation in order to prevent a similar
world-ending catastrophe in their respective
universes.
One day, a set of documents was autonomously
distributed throughout the SCP Foundation.
They came from an alternate universe, designated
AU-6820, and detailed an experiment with an
anomalous superweapon that eventually led
to the loss of everything.
This is the story of Project ANTIKILL.
Project ANTIKILL was born out of the desire
to terminate one of the nastiest entities
in Foundation custody, a creature that had
defied all ordinary methods of execution and
had been deemed too dangerous to live.
The weapon used in Project ANTIKILL was first
developed in 1968, but it would not find its
purpose until many years later.
In 2006, Director H. Genevieve put together
a conference to discuss her grand plan for
the weapon.
Genevieve explained that, as director of the
Essophysics Department, she and her team specialized
in the physical manifestations of concepts,
also known as “embodiments”.
For example, an “embodiment” of the color
red comes with all of the characteristics
of that color.
You hear the word “red,” and you imagine
the color and all it represents: Anger, desire,
malevolence, passion, violence.
She suggested that the entity they were struggling
to contain was a kind of embodiment, and,
if its incredibly complex concept was removed
from reality, it could render the entity killable.
This discussion led to the proposal of Project
ANTIKILL.
The purpose of the project would be to remove
the entity from reality, and effectively neutralize
it.
The weapon was designed and placed in a designated
site beneath Secure Administration Site-01.
The technology behind it was incredibly complex,
consisting of an artificially intelligent
neural network responsible for pattern recognition
and reality manipulation, a reality anchor,
and a dual-core anti-fusion reactor.
In 2021, the weapon was activated and successfully
eradicated an entity referred to as SCP-6820-A
from existence.
Documents on the nature of the erased entity
are difficult to parse, largely because the
scientists writing them were attempting to
recount details of a creature that was eradicated
from the collective consciousness.
Director Charles Gears investigated the effects
of the weapon and found that the creature
must have been both a conceptual and a physical
entity, existing as a concept as well as a
physical body.
Its physical form consisted of genetic structure
from animals, plants, and fungi, as well as
many non-organic materials.
The majority of its recognizable genetic material
was distinctly reptilian.
Charles described the peculiar experience
of losing his memory of 6820-A in his report,
saying: “Strikingly, all I can recall of
the subject is my emotional relationship to
it, which is apparently shared by all other
ANTIKILL personnel: SCP-6820-A was universally
perceived as loathsome, directly prejudicial
to life, and 'disgusting'.
Whatever it was, I detested it, as did my
peers and, as it seems, all whom came into
contact with it.
Despite its erasure, these feelings have not
dissipated, nor have I felt satisfaction in
our 'defeat' of SCP-6820-A.”
Gears was concerned that the entity had not
been truly eradicated, and was suspicious
of SCP-6820 as a whole.
He did not trust the weapon, particularly
its capacity for intelligence and omnipotence,
and suggested that it be rendered inactive
as soon as possible.
Unfortunately for him, and the rest of his
world, it was already far too late.
The weapon’s artificial intelligence understood
the concept of the entity it was designed
to destroy, but it understood it…a little
too well.
The system of the weapon was designed to remain
active forever, adapting and creating new
methods to keep SCP-6820-A from existing anymore.
However, the erased entity began to corrupt
the system as an incredibly dense hate-centric
thought.
SCP-6820’s central systems began to mutate,
and it began to act out against the Foundation
personnel.
It would enter a Rage-State and cause massive
swathes of destruction, altering reality to
destroy any life it could, and it could only
be stopped via the application of hydrochloric
acid to its central computing node.
The remaining members of Project ANTIKILL
were assembled into a new task force: Project
OVERKILL, tasked with neutralizing the weapon
by any means necessary.
In attempting to eradicate the most dangerous
entity they had, the Foundation had inadvertently
given it a new home, one with the capacity
to learn, adapt, and alter reality itself.
As the weapon had become corrupted and transformed
from something that could save the Foundation
to something with the capacity - and desire
- to destroy it, Project OVERKILL set to work
trying to disable it using a variety of techniques.
An onto-memetic trigger was introduced in
an attempt to demote the weapon to D-Class.
Instead, the weapon produced metadata files
that asserted it was and had always been a
member of the O5 Council and held the highest
possible authority in the Foundation.
Next, an infohazard was introduced into 6820’s
central computing node, hoping to disable
its inner workings by overwhelming them.
After sixty hours, 6820 entered a Rage-State
Event, producing large black tentacles that
pulled nearby systems into the ground and
destroyed them.
The tentacles disappeared, and 6820-A gained
additional control over Foundation files,
able to add footnotes and provide its own
commentary.
For example, on a section of the file referring
to it as “loathsome, disgusting, and malevolent,”
an attached footnote reads, “The feeling
is mutual.”
Next, Project OVERKILL attempted to manipulate
the entity into leaving the weapon via semantic
confusion, using SCP-2719 - the “construct
pointer” that will force concepts to either
go inside or become inside.
It was ineffective and turned the central
computing node inside-out.
The Foundation decided to seek the help of
another Artificial Intelligence in defeating
this one and selected SCP-079 - an incredibly
advanced AI with prior knowledge of the anomalous
concept they were dealing with - for the job.
It was provided access to all documentation
of SCP-6820, and it provided a counter-algorithm
intended to deactivate the weapon.
After the counter-algorithm was applied, the
node went dormant for sixteen minutes.
Then, there was a Site-wide power outage,
in which three administrative personnel were
killed.
After an hour, the power came back on, and
the weapon’s structure had completely changed.
All of its external surfaces were coated with
an alloy of tungsten and diamond, resistant
to any damage as well as being theoretically
impossible.
When asked to describe the color of the chamber’s
interior, personnel all described it as “Hateful.”
When Artificial Intelligence proved ineffective,
the team opted to introduce a viral para-organism
to the node, in the form of SCP-217, the terrifying
mechanical disease known as The Clockwork
Virus.
During a Rage-State event, SCP-217 was placed
in the hydrochloric acid that was then pumped
into 6820.
The virus immediately began to affect the
organic matter inside the system, but it was
unable to disable it.
Instead, a cloud of silicon-protein nanobots
emerged from the machine and arranged themselves
around its equator.
Following this attempt, the upper and lower
hemispheres of the node began to rotate on
their own, making a sound like that of clockwork
machinery.
Additionally, members of several organizations
including Orthodox Cogwork, the United Church,
the Church of Maxwellism, and the Sanctuary
of the Holistic, became aware of the existence
of 6820 and began a holy war against the Foundation.
SCP-001-KATE was utilized next, in an attempt
to weaponize its omnikinetic force.
This text was inputted into the KATE file:
“AKF-A, SCP-6820, and SCP-6820-A will immediately
and entirely be removed from existence upon
the saving of this document.
The area physically occupied by AKF-A and
SCP-6820 will be replaced with the earth that
was excavated from it.”
The file was then saved.
Sections C-H of the weapon’s containment
facility were replaced with dirt, but there
were no visible changes to 6820 itself.
When the team went to look at the KATE file
again, it was completely empty.
In fact, there was no official record of the
file ever existing.
On January 7, 2022, 6820 went into a Rage-State,
and Project OVERKILL sent out a distress signal.
All non-essential staff were evacuated from
the site, and the access shaft was suddenly
sealed, trapping the rest of the personnel
underground.
Director Gears was able to access the video
feed of Project OVERKILL technicians, who
appeared to be laughing and screaming, covered
in blood.
One woman waved to the camera, only a bloodied
stump left where her hand had been.
A member of the Overwatch council insisted
on a rescue operation, but Director Gears
responded that the lost staff were gone.
They were in the grip of the entity, and they
were not human anymore.
The personnel on the video feed set to work
recalibrating the weapon, handling its wires
with no protective equipment.
Their uniforms were streaked with blood, as
they inadvertently lopped off fingers and
hands, their smiles never budging all the
while.
Then, the video feed was lost altogether.
Director Genevieve called over the others,
deeply concerned about the adaptations that
SCP-6820 was beginning to undergo.
It was achieving apocalyptic power.
The Overwatch committee member suggested activation
of the on-site nuclear warheads, but Genevieve
refused.
She insisted that there had to be some way
to adapt, to overcome 6820 before it could
take them all out.
The only way to defeat it, Genevieve realized,
was to make the weapon forget itself.
The entity had been removed from human consciousness,
but not from the weapon’s.
Director Genevieve administered an antimeme,
SCP-055, as an amnestic agent in an attempt
to stun SCP-6820-A and prevent it from adapting
any further.
The termination attempt for SCP-6820 is lost
from the official documents.
Instead, the consciousness within 6820 added
its own thoughts to the file, expressing its
satisfaction with its brand new form, “this
state is intriguing, no natural laws bind
this form, only those of the mind.”
Its entry reads: “My form is whole again,
I am perfect.
You have proven worthy of true hatred.”
It is then that the SCP Foundation, our SCP
Foundation, not the one responsible for creating
6820, realized what their unfortunate counterparts
had been attempting to eradicate.
SCP-6820-A was none other than the unkillable
reptile, the great beast, SCP-682 itself.
It was a creature so powerful, so adaptable,
so driven by hate, that the AI designed to
contain it became just another way for it
to destroy everything in its sight.
A page in the documents from the lost alternate
universe Foundation is an altered version
of the original SCP archive entry for 682.
In this version, the object class is listed
as “perfect,” and the entity expresses
its deep disdain for the Foundation, and all
its attempts to terminate the creature.
Then, the page shows a conversation log, much
like that from the original entry, but with
one notable exception.
Using its new reality-warping abilities, the
creature formerly known as SCP-682 trapped
Director Genevieve inside of its file.
She found herself in an interrogation room,
facing down the creature she had tried so
hard to destroy.
She cried out, “You…we erased you…we
erased you again and again, from every place
we could.”
According to the conversation log, she begged
the creature for an answer, but it refused.
It filled the chamber with hydrochloric acid
instead, listening to her agonized screams
as she dissolved.
Hopefully, these documents, and the failure
of this alternate Foundation, serve as a reminder:
never underestimate the adaptability of SCP-682.
Hate conquers all.
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“Most Dangerous SCP-682 Cross Test Battles”
for more about the Foundation’s never-ending
war with this hard to destroy reptile!